revue de presse signée julien chez ida
bonjour julien bonjour film et nous
commençons par la presse américaine qui
revient longuement sur cette nomination
celle de cette juge à la cour suprême
confirmée par le sénat nomination
qualifié d'historique effectivement il
suffit de regarder cette photo qui
s'affiche en une du new york times avec
un job hayden tout sourire prenant les
mains de la toute nouvelle juge de la
cour suprême kts et angie bronn au
moment de la confirmation de cette
dernière voté par le sénat après
plusieurs jours de débats cette juge va
devenir la première juge afro américaine
a accédé à la cour suprême c'est une
première en deux sont de 33 ans
d'existence elle va remplacer à notre
juge démocrate stephen breyer qui à 81 3
ans va bientôt prendre sa retraite d'ici
quelques mois mais comme le rappelle ce
dessin qu'on va bientôt voir de matt
davis le chemin vers la plus haute cour
de justice américaine n'a pas été un
long fleuve tranquille loin de là le
conte et républicains s'étaient donné
pour mission de faire craquer la juge
lors de ses auditions des questions
parfois grossières ou provocante
rappelle le washington post un spectacle
qualifié même de honteux pour la
démocratie américaine notamment lorsque
les sénateurs les plus conservateurs
deal journal ont accusés la juge d'avoir
défendu des pédophiles ou des
terroristes accusations sans fondement
appelle le quotidien qui accusent les
républicains les plus conservateurs
d'avoir utilisé 7 cette audition comme
une tribune pour en prend vie des des
élections de mid-term en novembre
prochain on parle maintenant de
l'ukraine de la situation à marioupol
dans le sud est du pays où chaque jour
on découvre julien des nouveaux core
d'habitants victimes des bombardements
répétés de la ville oui effectivement au
moins 300 civils tués rien qu'on ne le
crains que dans le bombardement du
théâtre de mario paul d'après les
autorités ukrainiennes et on peut lire
dans le guardian le guardian le
témoignage incroyable denis three year
in ici cet ukrainien qu'on voit ici qui
se trouvaient dans les environs le 16
mars dernier lorsque l'attaqué a eu lieu
il décrit l'explosion massive les cris
les hurlements et puis les corps
d'adultes et d'enfants couvert de sang
après ce drame il raconte qu'il décide
de quitter la ville mais celle-ci est
encerclée par les russes alors il se
fabrique un équipement de fortune pour
pouvoir partir par la mer d'azov il fuit
finalement par la mer en pleine nuit
deux heures trente de nage vers l'ouest
direction l'ouest dans une eau
extrêmement froide il réussit finalement
à atteindre une station balnéaire et à
se mettre en sécurité les il a eu la
chance de pouvoir partir d'autres n'ont
pas eu cette chance oui on avait appris
il ya quelques jours la mort du
réalisateur lituanien mantas cuvée
d'aravis us alors qu'il se trouvait à
marioupol il s'agit d'un cinéaste
reconnu qu'ils avaient notamment tourner
un documentaire en 2016 sur la ville
portuaire documentaire qui avait été
sélectionné dans de nombreux festivals
prestigieux comme la berlinale et il se
trouvait à marioupol pour disent-ils
tourner une forme de suite sauf que
cette suite malheureusement ne verra
jamais le jour le matin de lituanie
apporte de plus amples informations sur
sa mort on avait d'abord dit que la
voiture dans laquelle il se trouvait
avait été touché par une requête est
bien s'accompagne aujourd'hui donne une
toute autre version des faits elles
affirment que des soldats russes l'ont
arrêté après l'avoir reconnu puis
exécutés d'une balle dans la tête elle
est parvenue finalement ramener la
dépouille de son mari en lituanie une
enquête a été ouverte autre sujet dans
la presse julien schell dans le royaume
uni le gouvernement de boris johnson est
de nouveau empêtré dans une nouvelle
polémique qui concerne cette fois son
ministre des finances oui cela fait
plusieurs jours que le visage du
richissime nac le chancelier de
l'échiquier comme on l'appelle en
angleterre apparaît à la une des
journaux britanniques car celui ci
aurait permis à sa propre épouse
d'échapper à l'impôt sur les sociétés
elle perçoit des dividendes annuels
grâce à la société de sa famille basées
à l'étranger on parle quand même
d'environ 11 millions de livres c'est le
quotidien d independence qui avait
révélé cette information c'est légal
mais est ce que c'est vraiment éthique
se demande le guardian la réponse est
clairement non pour le journal de gauche
le quotidien parle même d'une faute de
la part du ministre cela révèle à quel
point elle comprend peu l'avis de la
plupart des gens qu'il soumet maintenant
au choc du coût de la vie fin de
citation car au delà du problème éthique
cette polémique intervient au moment où
des britanniques ont vu le coût de la
vie explosé depuis le 1er avril + 54% de
dépenses rien que dans l'énergie
augmentation aussi sur le coût des
produits alimentaires une telle hausse
ne s'étaient pas vus dans le pays depuis
les et 50 rappelle le quotidien suisse
le temps à tel point écrit le journal
les britanniques ont seront peut-être
bientôt à se demander s'il faudra soit
manger soit se chauffer on parle bien de
la cinquième puissance économique
mondiale on continue parler du royaume
uni mais sur un tout autre angle jeudi à
celle d'à puisque le groupe mythique
pink floyd sort de sa retraite et pour
une bonne raison oui retour éphémère
mais ça fait du bien en ces temps
troublés il faut le dire regardez cette
photo il y a quelques cheveux blancs
plus mais l'énergie surtout longvic et
bien là les pink floyd viennent de
sortir cette nuit un nouveau titre
inédit événement musical puisque celle
de tout premier titre du groupe depuis
28 ans c'est quand même pas mal une
seule chanson cette fois ci pour
soutenir les ukrainiens dans cette
guerre qu'il est qu'ils subissent depuis
plus d'un mois maintenant le guitariste
gilmour qu'on va david gilmour qu'on va
juste ici se dit dégoûtée par cette
invasion et il a fait ce morceau à
l'initiative d'un chanteur et craignent
un avec qui avec elle a collaboré
chanteur qui se dit aussi fan du groupe
des pink floyd à noter malheureusement
l'absence de roger waters l'autre
guitariste légendaire du groupe avec qui
il s'est brouillé depuis plusieurs
années et ce ne sont pas ses récentes
déclarations ambiguës sur la base russe
qui vont arranger les choses merci
beaucoup julien schell da c'était la
revue de presse dans pareille direct